[Musik]
versinken dem trash-tv frisst uns der
wohlfahrtsstaat auf und sind die
deutschen voll geworden darüber wollen
wir heute abend diskutieren und damit
herzlich willkommen zu fällen nach acht
meine gäste haben sie werden ihn kennen
haben glückler er will vom leben viel
und das zeigt schon die anzahl seiner
berufe es designer unternehmer
lebensberater buchautor und was ich am
spannendsten finde eine einzigartige
kunstfigur eine einzigartige marke schön
dass sie da sind sehr glücklich heute ja
so dem sich ehemalige spitzenpolitiker
der fdp und vor über einem halben jahr
aus der politik ausgestiegen darüber hat
sie auch ein buch geschrieben das heißt
die reißleine sie konnte nicht mehr
politische debatten liegen jedoch
weiterhin am herzen schön dass sie da
sind henrik m bruder er ist welt
kolumnist und autor zahlreicher bücher
sein bestes oder eines der besten laut
ihm selbst die irren von zion heute
spricht er darüber wie der
wohlfahrtsstaat uns auffrisst martin
limbeck unternehmer und autor er findet
die deutschen sind voll geworden und die
jungen würden zu sehr an ihrer
work-life-balance hängen ich bin sehr
gespannt auf die debatten heute abend
mein name ist nina schenk ich freue mich
ihren gastgeberin sein zu dürfen meine
these heute ist mal keine politische ich
dachte mir beginnen abend heute mal ein
wenig anders meine these ist deutschland
braucht eine queen warum die deutschen
sind ja eher ein mutiges völkchen ohne
fehler matter glanz und gloria wirkliche
stars haben den letzten jahren auch
nicht hervorgebracht oder wie
entertainer thomas gottschalk 1 hierbei
fiel nach achter sehr schräg von mir
gesagt hat wir versinken im 12 gefeiert
werde nur noch der größte müll von trash
tv im fernsehen über die branche daraus
entstehen und nicht zu vergessen mit
denen ich sehr auf kriegsfuß stehe aldi
in fluren sollen oberflächlichen
youtuber wenn man dann auf das platinum
thronjubiläum der queen schaut wen es
hier gleich auch im bilde teppich da
sieht man ganz genau die bilder berühren
wie sie auf dem balkon steht umgeben von
charles william und kate und auch ihren
enkeln ich finde die deutschen brauchen
selbst auch eine queen wir brauchen eine
person in einem zeitalter des egoismus
die mehr darauf schaut was man auch für
andere tun kann und deswegen plädiere
ich heute abend dafür mehr drauf eine
queen und ich bin sehr gespannt wie das
mpeg la sieht ja ich stelle mich zur
verfügung also das wäre etwas was ich
gut machen können der repräsentieren und
bisschen glanz bringen aber auch nicht
nur das auch mich um die menschen
kümmern wenn ich mir anschaue wie viele
termine alleine prinzessin an jedes jahr
verbringt wie viel wie viele termine das
königshaus abliefert im ganzen jahr da
werden altersheime besucht da werden
leute geehrt ich denke immer bei uns in
deutschland was was ja gut wir haben
einen präsidenten
aber irgendwie sehe ich die termine ich
sehe die nähe nicht zu den menschen und
und das finde ich schon sehr
bedauerlich und sehr schade gerade in
zeiten des lockdown oder überhaupt in
schwierigen zeiten auch jetzt in leben
wir ja einen sehr schwierigen zeiten da
braucht man ein staatsoberhaupt wie wie
die queen die ja die die für die
menschen da ist sie den menschen mut
macht die allein durch erscheint euer
erscheinen das kann auch ein
bundespräsident ein bundespräsident kann
wenn sie denn das ganze aufwand den
menschen mut macht die menschen ja
einfach verzaubert und bei uns wird
eigentlich so irgendwie schon lange
nicht mehr verzaubert in deutschland
also der zauber ist weg da ist aber auch
generell bei den stars oder würden sie
mir da widersprechen für das was für
stars wir versinken ja schon ein wenig
im trash sie verehren ja marlene
dietrich habe ich genese afragola
pritsche rauch also gibt es solches ist
da ist denn überhaupt noch und braucht
man ja ja das sind jetzt viele fragen es
werden auch in amerika also man man
macht diese stars nicht mehr in diesem
ausmaß aber
mir passiert oft dass junge junge
menschen mit 18 also ich habe sehr viele
fans auch so mit sieben jahren aber so
mit 16 18 fotos wollen und dann sagt der
tierfreund oder sowas ist so machst du
jetzt foto mit ihm sagt er ja legendär
völlig ohne und und die leute suchen
weder die leute suchen nach nach glanz
die leute suchen nach vorbildern und das
ist das was viele an wir mögen das ich
dass ich ein stil hat der konsequent ist
der extravagant ist der die wollen nicht
alles so aussehen wie ich aber ich bin
authentisch und ich bin durch gary und
und bin für viele ein vorbild in dem was
ich lebe dass ich mein leben so ebenso
lässt sich also haben wir einen
richtigen waren deutschen stream wir
haben wir jemanden der fundamenten der
authentisch ist und der eine klare linie
hat und wenn eben eine klare linie hat
dann wird er auch wahrgenommen wird auch
entsprechend wahrgenommen das wort da
müsste man da erst mal interpretieren
wir brauchen mehr persönlichkeiten wir
haben keine persönlichkeiten mehr das
fängt also ich möchte gar nicht sagen
wir haben keine stars aber wir haben
keine persönlichkeiten mehr frau suding
haben wir den in der politik
persönlichkeiten mögliche vorbilder zu
denen man aufschauen kann ich weiß gar
nicht ob die politik dafür da ist dass
sie vorbilder oder menschen kreiert zu
dem man aufschauen kann die haben vor
allem den job und die politik zu machen
dass das leben der menschen vernünftig
zu gestalten oder das einfacher und
besser zu machen das ist sicherlich
nicht immer gut gegangen in den letzten
jahren und dann ist es nicht gut
herausforderungen wir sprechen ja gleich
noch darüber während der korona punjabi
finde ich hat die deutsche politik sehr
versagt sie hat sich an kindern
versündigt
die haben sehr unter dem lockeren
gesprächen gleich noch drüber aber wir
haben auch unser grundgesetz komplett
vergessen es wurde mit füßen getreten
also unsere werte sind mit füßen
getreten worden und das alles nur sage
ich jetzt mal wegen einer pandemie hat
man all das was unser land ausmacht man
einfach vergessen und das macht mir
angst und sorge und das entfremdet mich
von meinem land und ich glaube das geht
auch sehr viel anderen menschen so sind
sie auch entfremdet vielleicht weil
vorbilder fehlen vielleicht auch wegen
dem politics den hellweg absoluter wir
sind dabei einfach überall im mittelmaß
zu versinken wir sind super gut wenn man
über kinder zum beispiel sprechen an der
schule was wird er heute gelernt in
seinem trabis später nachdem ein
generell schauen auf die
persönlichkeiten dieses landes ist
absolut wir sind voll geworden wir geben
keine extra malen wir sind immer fleißig
wenn man tatsächlich sieht wir ungefähr
45 millionen menschen die praktisch am
arbeiten teilnehmen voll und teilzeit
wenn man der gallup studie trauen
marktindex haben
menschen die überhaupt noch wert
geschaffen in deutschland und wir gehen
nur noch über reiche reicher reiche
waren 0,1 prozent in deutschland den
vermögen von 5,6 millionen und 1 prozent
von 1,3 millionen man sich mal anschaut
reden wir über eine gruppe von 80.000
menschen oder werden schon wieder über
eine reichensteuer und gehen nicht an
die mittelschicht dran die einfach mehr
leisten könnte bei einem statt dass wir
jetzt schon über die extra meile
sprechen die queen zb steht für mich
eigentlich für respekt für demo dafür
weniger egoistisch zu sein wenn sie über
die extra meile sprechen dann
verknüpften sie eigentlich dass die
menschen mehr egoistisch sein müssten
bei der extra meile geht ja nicht darum
welche go ist ist das glücksrad schon
gesagt wir brauchen vorbilder ich glaube
auch wir bräuchten sie in der politik wo
ich hinschaue wenn man sich die
wahlbeteiligung anschaut da sieht man ja
auch da dass die menschen einfach sich
breitgemacht haben versorgt sind das was
da ist lang und eben auch nicht ich habe
noch niemanden kennengelernt damit 35
stunden finanziell frei geworden ist
herr broder steinmeier oder harald
glöckler als präsident naja machen sie
es mich nicht so einfach das ist dann
die antwort na ja es gibt eine dritte
möglichkeit wie man sie sich entscheiden
sie verlangen wirklich zu viel von mir
also gut ich kandidiere
als premier schon richtig angesprochen
aber wissen sie ich war immer ein
republikaner
und seit herr steinmeier regiert bin ich
für die einführung der monarchie ich
möchte auch etwas glanz und glamour an
der spitze haben aber eben nicht nur
glanz und glamour es muss auch begründet
sein oder verwurzelt sein und das haut
nicht hin mit allem das bag der glockner
man kann der monarchie und man kann eine
repräsentanz nicht aus dem nichts
schreiber nicht nein ich war deswegen
das ist so als würden sie
einem einen 17 jährigen oma sagen die
soll sich wieder auf ihrer jugend
besinnen nicht wahr und das make-up
entsprechend ändern das wird keine
juveniler schönheit mehr werden und wir
haben das problem überhaupt die
personaldecke in deutschland ist so dünn
wissen sie wie die gegenwärtige
regierung anschaue frage ich mich was
haben die vorher gemacht waren die in
wir auf spitze und haben dann die
einmalige gelegenheit bekommen die ränge
eins und naja ich meine zum beispiel
unser großartiger verteidigungsminister
vor allem brea ich habe ein problem mit
namen aber ich glaube sie heißt wirklich
so bringt jedenfalls dass die frau die
immer mit ihrem 21-jährigen sohn
verreist weil der irgendwie noch nicht
alleine da ein ticket kaufen
ich habe lange personaldecke wir können
noch nicht mal ein nachfolger für
gottschalk finden und ein land in dem
die meisten schon als es gelten ist
eigentlich verloren das hat nur noch
nicht gemerkt dass es so im auslauf den
berg runter rollt deswegen so sich jetzt
für eine monarchie bericht um das becken
gegenüber sie werden allerdings auch nur
meiner zweite wahl das problem ist nur
ich weiß nicht wer die erste wahl aber
die 2 immerhin wer immer wieder ja alle
pole position auf alle fälle sie können
sich vorstellen natürlich ich bitte sie
meine herrschen muss ich noch mal
anschauen
glanz und gloria gloria apropos glanz
und gloria vielleicht könnten sie sich
den job teilen mit gloria von thurn oder
aber so dass wir sind auch dafür nicht
was wärst du hier hat auch einen sinn
für repräsentanten wertheim nahmen die
alten namen bürger und ein bisschen
verrückt ist sie auch aber das gehört
dazu aber nein wir haben wir haben ihn
schon sehr bitter wir haben ein
langweiler an der spitze da immer die
sätze falsch betont der mine durch das
setzen von 1000 gedanken tiefe erzeugen
zu können das funktioniert nicht die
wichtigen themen das ist ja auch sehr
positiv hat herr glück ja auch schon
falls er dann präsident werden die queen
wäre es wenn man sich heute ein
wichtiges thema mit genau was in sehr am
herzen liegt er glück ja ja das große
problem bei uns und das ist aber auch
schon seit da können wir schon seit 30
jahren ist dass die kinder keine lobby
haben und
dass viele dass wir seit jahrzehnten
so immer zeug hat wenigstens drei
millionen kinder unter der armutsgrenze
haben die unter armutsgrenze leben und
ich habe situationen erlebt als
botschafter fürs kinderherz sorgen für
andere organisationen dass kinder uns
das brot aus den händen gerissen haben
hunger aber die kinder verhungern ja
nicht nur
weil sie nichts zu essen bekommen die
verhungern ja auch geistig also die
haben
die eltern sind überfordert die eltern
teilweise
alkoholiker kümmert sich überhaupt nicht
um die kinder die kinder kriegen keine
lehre vermittelt die kinder sind
außenseiter in der schule wir leben
heute in einer zeit wenn man nicht die
richtigen outfits an hat nicht in der
richtigen
winter richtige clique es dann ist man
sowieso verloren das ist man außenseiter
und diese kinder keiner keiner ist da
der in irgendwelche werte beibringen
kann die sind völlig auf sich gestellt
und diese kinder sind teilweise
teilweise hoch intelligent aber die sind
verloren die trifft viele driften von
den ab und ja was wollen wir für eine
zukunft kreieren wenn wir uns um die
kinder nicht kümmern werden wir wenn wir
keine werte mehr vermitteln und das
versuche ich seit 30 jahren versuche ich
das mal so kämpfe ich und dafür und
mache dinge ich habe eine große gala
inszeniert vor vielen jahren das
deutsche kinderhilfswerk und hatte da
dann freunde von mir
bonnie tyler bouck nielsen angelika
milster sind kostenlos aufgetreten da
hatten wir dann ich weiß noch wir haben
frau merkel angeschrieben wir hatten
frau fand allein damals als
familienministerin gegen ghana
unterschreiben sie vom harry lange
radikale
charity gala und die hatten alle keine
zeit und die frau von der leyen wollte
nicht fotografiert werden mit ranzen und
frau kyla weil die so groß sein und dann
die sie so klein auf dem foto und solche
sachen und das schlimme ist
der lok dann hat das alles jetzt noch
verschärft und ich sehe
da eine katastrophe auch hinzu kommen
weil wir wer es gibt keine werte mehr es
gibt auch die sich diese kinder haben
keinen kein halt man muss auch
organisationen unterstützen es ist ja
alles geld da es ist ja alles gelder
aber seit 20 30 jahren nicht für diese
kinder muss organisationen unterstützen
die sich dieser kinder annehmen die
ideen eine möglichkeit bieten von
zuhause ich komme selbst aus einem
elternhaus das schrecklich war der vater
ein schläger die kinder die haben zu
hause horror die die sind ausgegrenzt in
der schule die haben die am hunger dann
kommen sie auf die schiefe bahn
vielleicht hat es wurden während wundert
ja und dann gibt es vereine die die
bieten den möglichkeiten dass sie
nachmittags hinkommt sie essen bekommen
dass sie ihre schulaufgaben machen
können das waren lockt dann auch alles
geschlossen war auch dann alles wieder
erledigt alles weg wieder da hat sie
ihre eigene kindheit geprägt dass sie
sich so sehr für die kinder engagierte
ja ich habe das große glück haben da
muss ich kurz verdanken dass ich ein
extrem starke persönlichkeit bin und ich
mich dann
trotz dieser beiden meine kindheit war
kriegszustand also ich kann mich nicht
eine sekunde hin solange ich versuche
darüber nachzudenken daran erinnern dass
ich als kind nicht angst hatte ob meine
mutter blutend am boden liegt oder oder
tot ist oder noch lebt der vater mit
spalter hinterher und ich habe mich mit
sechs jahren ausgeklinkt dachte ich na
also so geht das nicht du musst nur
bessere welt kreieren der andere welt
kreieren hat beschlossen dem motto prinz
zu werden
beschlossen jede frau zur prinzessin zu
machen das leben sollte schön sein
natürlich habe ich da nicht ein motiv
erkaufen gedacht hab mich aber gleich
dran gemacht filme angeschaut und das
ist halt aus mir geworden ich bin
einfach schöner dass ich versuche die
welt schöner zu machen wird aber immer
schwieriger ja ich kann es inzwischen
nur noch mal in dem ich schön strahle
und viele andere das sehen und daran
sich erfreut und offensichtlich gelingt
es mir ja dass ich ganz viele junge
menschen inspirieren denn die sprechen
mich an da kommen 87 jährige kinder und
sagen ich finde es toll und es ist so
klasse und und auch ja und das wollen
sie jetzt noch verstärkt da machen auch
die gleiche ja ich möchte nein ich habe
jetzt auch wieder das gefühl dass jetzt
mittal mit dem alten lockdown mit krieg
mit allem was wir haben die kinder jetzt
wieder völlig jetzt fahren sie wieder
völlig und das raster da konnte kümmert
sich gar keiner mehr aber bitte wenn wir
jetzt nicht starten unsere kinder
unseren kindern chancen zu geben was
werden wir für eine gesellschaft was
sind das für eine gesellschaft in 20
frage will ich gerne meinen bruder geben
was sind für für eine gesellschaft was
werden wir für einen gesellschafter in
20 jahren wir sind eine wohlstands
verwahrlost der gesellschaft und
deswegen stimme ich mit mir nur zum teil
überein es sind natürlich nicht die
kinder schulter sowie sind wie sie sind
wir haben in der bundesrepublik über 150
familien
hilfsmaßnahmen am geld mangelt es nicht
ganz im gegenteil gilt wir millionen
weise ausgeschüttet was schlecht läuft
das überhaupt nicht läuft es gibt kaum
noch eine verantwortung der eltern weil
sich irgendwie alle darauf geeinigt
haben der staat wird das richten und der
stadt kann es nicht er sollte es auch
nicht und ich bitte sie elternschaft ist
eine sehr persönliche angelegenheit
ich bin dagegen persönliche
angelegenheiten zu verstaatlichen oder
zu vergesellschaften
wenn die leute keine verantwortung haben
dann ingenieuren bitte haben sie keine
kinder kriegen also dingen mangelt es
nicht am geld also herr bruder hat
gerade gesagt am geldmangels nicht woran
mangelt dann dass die kinder haben und
weiter steigt also eher bruder hat recht
es gibt ein unfassbar riesigen strauß an
familienpolitischen leistungen die sind
teilweise aber so kompliziert also ich
nehme alle einmal nur
leistung die wohl von dem nur 30 prozent
der kinder die überhaupt einen anspruch
darauf haben profitieren davon weil es
so kompliziert es sind so unbekannt das
ist einfach nicht an der jugend in
diesem land ist alles
am ende die die wissen wie sie sich
durch diesen antrag dschungel
durchforsten ja die können da
einigermaßen gut von leben andere gehen
komplett den bach runter und klar
natürlich haben familie und eltern eine
große verantwortung und das kann man
auch gar nicht oft genug betont
allerdings das thema bildung ist eine
staatliche aufgabe und da hat der staat
schon eine riesengroße verantwortung der
kommt er aber rast könnte die larissa
tun gezielt was müsste der staat tun
damit weniger kinder in armut leben wir
jetzt meinen letzten zwei jahre anguckt
dann müsste man unterricht erst mal
stattfinden lassen das wäre schon die
erste folge der zone ist das ist ja
schon nicht passiert so dass wir einfach
die situation haben wir ja glück mal
beschreibt das wie einfach die in den
einfluss aus dem elternhaus auf ein
späteres leben oft ein erfolg in der
bildung also und damit auch auf den auf
die möglichkeit etwas aus dem leben zu
machen die träume zu verwirklichen sie
hatten einen traum sie konnten ihn
verwirklichen das kann ich aber oft nur
wenn ich auch eine gewisse bildung haben
abschlüsse da sind wenn ich eine
ausbildung studium machen kein gegenpol
zu dem zudem
zu hause wo gar nicht hat findet ein
gegenpol das überhaupt sehe es gibt auch
andere möglichkeiten oder es gibt auch
ein anderes es gibt auch andere
andere eltern andere familien und andere
herangehensweisen vergessen ich habe oft
gefragt wenn ich dann da waren ein paar
hundert kinder und das heißt was willst
du werden und dann sagt ihr eigentlich
möchte prinzessin werden du kannst eine
werten ich wollte auch in port-au-prince
werden ich bin auch einer geworden und
ich was mir gelungen ist ich habe so
fünf sechs mal haben wir junge menschen
geschrieben die durch mich aus wirklich
schwierigen verhältnissen und schon am
abdriften warnt die kurve gekriegt haben
einen beruf erlernt haben und sich das
nie getraut hätten weil sie gedacht
haben ich bin ein looser ich kann das
nicht und sie auch spaß an den direkten
zusammenarbeit mit kindern hängt das
habe ich ja gemacht über jahrzehnte habe
ich direkt ja immer wir sind ja das sind
ja auch mit dem deutschen philipp es
heute immer an brennpunkten gegangen ja
deshalb sieht man ja sie eigentlich
sieht man dann ja auch was los ist und
dann kommt natürlich immer das argument
bleibt würde aber die eltern kriegen ja
geld aber de verkaufen das sage ich ja
aber dass wir müssen erstmal dem kind
helfen das ist ja mal völlig
unwesentlich was der etwa das elternteil
macht aber wenn wir jetzt ich möchte das
noch mal sagen wenn es jetzt
einrichtungen gibt wo die kinder hin
können wenn sie dass sie endlich mal von
zu hause auch rauskommen dass sie ein
ein ort überhaupt haben wo sie hin
können nicht irgendwo auf der straße
herumlungern wo es nur noch kriminell
werden ja dann hat man den slogans auch
die hat man auch alle geschlossen und
jetzt ist es so dass vieles auch gar
nicht mehr gar nicht mehr geöffnet so
dass das leute auch nicht mehr bereit
sind dass es funktioniert er auch nur
mit ehrenamtlichen helfern zum größten
teil und da finde ich da müsst ihr auch
ein psychologe mit drin sein da müsste
auch möchte auch eine lehrkraft sein
sollen millionen von psychologen
pädagogen dran sind nicht zu weniger
leute in der kinderversorgung tätigt
sondern zu viel und bei allem respekt
für ihre leistungen das was die eltern
versäumen kann der staat nicht
ausgleichen nein aber ich rufe nach mehr
staat äußerst suspekt am ende kriegen
dann kleine zombies die sich in der
deutschen jugend ich hätte auch gern
mehr staat aber das was man einen haken
also wenn wir das noch mal sehen mit
denen ich bin auch kinderlachen
botschafter und wir kriegen auch mit wie
schwierig sein geld ranzukommen ist das
wenn man was privat jedes siebte kind
hat eben auch kein bett in deutschland
wir halt wirklich sagt nur der punkt ist
der total arbeitet die eltern fort waren
ich wollte auch meine kinder nicht von
lehrern erziehen lassen nur weil in die
schule schauen wo es anfängt also wenn
wir auch über eltern sprechen müssen wir
da ja schon hingehen in der pandemie
wird zugemacht hat beim 30 prozent mehr
häusliche gewalt gehabt und auch viel
schlimmere dinge mit kindern der zweite
punkt ist versuchen sie mal digitales
buch für zu hause zu bekommen gab es ja
gar nicht das heißt dann fangen wir dann
auch mal an in der schule andere themen
bei zu lassen wenn er glückler kein
weder grundstudium hat oder so wie ich
motivation treten an der schule wird gar
nicht zugelassen und eine freundin von
mir macht tatsächlich lehrerseminar und
ich war schockiert wie sind wir sagte
die erste frage die ideen stellt wie
denken sie über kinder ich habe erst
gedacht die frage stellt sich auch ein
lehrer nicht doch bei viele lehrer auch
ein schlechtes bild von kindern haben
weil ihm schlecht erzogen sind weil die
keinen respekt mehr haben und deswegen
natürlich schon zu hause auch an aber
wir müssen ganz andere fächer in der
schule haben die
persönlichkeitsentwicklung wie man lerne
ich denn mal was eine gmbh ist oder mich
selbstständig machen wie komme ich denn
überhaupt dann solche ideen wie ein
glück war das kann ich heute nur bei
instagram aber alle anderen teile gibt
es ja auch helikopter eltern also wir
sehen ja auch das phänomen dass kinder
wirklich fast über überwacht total rasen
sie rasenmäher eltern oder helikopter
jahr hinweg schon mal frei gemäht
absolut kinder kennen ja keine in
anführungsstrichen im mittelstand noch
mal keine notwehr da ist alles da die
fahren in urlaub der kühlschrank ist
voll ihr studium wird meistens
finanziert die haben keine extra jobs
mörder geht kann einmal da man den rasen
mähen und da müssen wir wieder ansetzen
werte wieder schaffen denn nochmal die
dies im moment machen sind viel zu klein
wenn wir die unternehmer nämlich den
mittelstand den motor ja noch mehr
besteuern kann ich verstehen dass die
heute darüber nachdenken auszuwandern
weil wo soll sie herkommen den letzten
zehn jahren
bleiben bei den kindern hingegen haben
ja auch ganz viele die nicht in urlaub
fahren und sie sondern die irgendwo in
einer ein zimmer wohnung mit aggressivem
vater der dieb oder kurz und klein
schlägt er abstellen die alkoholisierte
ist das kind kennt auch ein paar war es
ist ständig terror zu hause und gar
keine möglichkeit hat irgendwo raus zu
kommen und aus dieser kiste gar nicht
rauskommt panische angst hat also da ist
nicht die frage mit den urlaub fahren
wir haben wieder den start der
überreguliert ist und die behörden nicht
helfen wie wäre es damit den eltern die
kinder zu entziehen offenbar ist die
größte gefährdung stelle für kinder
deren eigene eltern haben was ja
übrigens stimmt beim missbrauchs
geschichten bei verletzungen durch
prügel elternhaus eine ganz gefährliche
sache her gehen sie um mitternacht durch
kreuzberg spazieren
eigenen vater zu unterhändler darf ich
ihnen eine persönliche frage stellen
vielleicht auch muss nochmal zu
kennzeichnen den kindern wenn man selber
eine schwere kindheit wie sie auch
erlebt hat kann man das jemals komplett
verarbeiten oder briefe seien eigentlich
für immer
also man muss irgendwann deckel drauf
man aber 100 prozent verarbeiten kann
man nicht das drama ist je länger man
darüber nachdenkt desto eher
desillusioniert da wird man ich habe am
anfang nur
beginnend mit meinem vater und
irgendwann habe ich dann festgeschrieben
meine mutter hat auch mit schuld daran
und dann fiel mir irgendwann ein habe
ich fotos durchgeschaut und dann kamen
wir einfordern von einem bekannten der
familie in die hände dafür ein dass die
haben mich mit sechs jahren sexuell
belästigt hat das hatte ich völlig
verdrängt also irgendwann muss man
deckel drauf machen weil das wird immer
schlimmer so es wird nicht besser und da
waren so viele punkte ich bin nur sehr
dankbar und ich danke gott dass ich
diese stärke hatte und diese kraft die
haben ja nicht alle und dass ich eben
nicht abgedriftet bin und sondern dass
ich gesagt habe man kreiere ich mir eben
nimmt der eigene welt dann lass dir mal
machen ich mache ich habe damit nichts
zu tun ich bin irgendwelchen falschen
film ich mache meine eigene welt und
dann bin ich aber auch wieder auf das
unverständnis gestoßen der gesellschaft
wenn ein junger mann rum läuft und sich
da anzieht wie ein prinz wähler dann
wird auch wieder gelacht und und und als
ich dann begonnen habe meine shows zu
machen wird auch über mich gelacht und
schwul und gelacht und wie läuft herum
und isst ja so und jetzt wenn jetzt
kommen die alten sagen denn ich fand sie
immer schon toll das war ja das kann ich
mir denken ja ich bin teil dass sie die
stärke und auch die erfahrungen der
kinder selbst in das engagement für
kinder steigt die kinder finden toll
dass ich wenn sie gefragt werden was
finden sie an der klöckner toll dann
sagen sie ich finde toll das ja sein
ding macht der letzten leben wird
burkhard nicht am arsch überhaupt das
andere gut finden und so möchte ich auch
lebenswichtiges motto so leben wie man
selbst lust drauf hat wir bleiben bei
kindern ein ganz wichtiges thema und
geben an katja suding
ja mir geht es da noch mal um die kinder
und vor allen dingen um die schulen wir
haben ja zu beginn der pandemie relativ
wenig daten gehabt über die pandemie das
hat sicher
wesentlichen auch nicht geändert das tut
man sich wahrscheinlich auch mit der
evaluierung der maßnahmen so schwer was
wir aber von anfang an schon wussten und
diejenigen die guten menschenverstand
haben die konnten das auch ohne studien
schnell herausfinden dass die schließung
von kitas und von schulen von
spielplätzen der der wegfall von sport-
und freizeitmöglichkeiten der
kontaktverbot für kinder dass das
natürlich immense ganz ganz schreckliche
und schlimme auswirkungen auf unsere
kinder und jugendlichen haben würde wer
diesen menschenverstand nicht besitzt
der konnte sie gerne auch die vielen
studien zu hilfe nehmen da gab es ja
unterschiedlichste von die cops ii
studie aus dem universitätsklinikum
hamburg eppendorf oder die leipziger
studie oder jetzt kürzlich in der car
report die haben alle gezeigt dass die
psychischen probleme von kindern und
jugendlichen massiv zugenommen haben
essstörungen depressionen massive
gewichtszunahme also wirklich massive
probleme die unsere kinder gehabt haben
und wir können bis heute nicht
nachweisen dass schulschließungen
irgendwie geholfen hätte den kindern im
sinne der pandemie bekämpfung der
hilfe vor dem virus
etwas gutes zu tun kinder sind keine
pandemie treiber sie haben auch nicht
unter den virus gelitten aber es wird
ganz sicher wissen dass sie eben unter
den massnahmen gelitten haben und
deswegen kann ich nur jeden der auch nur
irgendwie drüber nachdenkt im herbst
wieder solche drastischen maßnahmen zu
ersinnen nur sagen hände weg von unseren
kinder wird unsere kinder das nie wieder
antun es muss eine garantie geben für
einen präsenzunterricht für offene kitas
und offene schulen die kinder die damals
schon schwer hatten die sind so weit
zurückgefallen und das dürfen wir
unseren kindern wieder anschauen also
wenn ich mir anschaue dass wir felder
ich habe da gerade ein bild für die
zweijährige enkeltochter von meinem mann
wie das kind
freudestrahlend angetan kommt und sie
darf aber denn europa nicht umarmen und
nicht überwiegend so was passiert mit
dem kind wenn die die das ist ja ein sie
hat dieses bedürfnis den opa sie ist
voller liebe zu umarmen nein das darfst
du nicht ja was passiert das passiert da
passiert ganz viel hat das ist doch
wie können diese menschen noch überhaupt
soziale kontakte später aufbauen wie wie
werden die groß gerade in diesen jungen
jahren wie wir werden die kurse so
furchtbar das ist entsetzlich und auch
dieses dieses unverständnis und diese
enttäuscht und jetzt die unsicherheit
das jetzt nicht auf den opa zu darf ja
das bleibt das bleibt das bleibt absolut
wenn diese klaren sind sie kennen ja gar
nichts anderes machen mehr sind ja
aufgewachsen und dann haben sie alle
schon das handy es geht nur noch über
handy dann bald also herr bruder sehen
auch ein enkelkind haben sie das
gehandhabt in der pandemie und kann es
sein durch leid aber dass wir bald
wieder die show lockt das habe ich hab's
gar nicht gehandhabt unsere tochter und
ihr mann haben das wunderbar gehandhabt
ich glaube das kind ist ziemlich normal
geworden dass
das kind es normal und gut drauf was
kommt nach mir das mache ich mir keine
sorgen aber ich muss noch 14 und dagegen
sagen wir reden ja über deutschland habe
die situation die sie beschreiben ist
keine deutsche spezialität dieser
pandemie und der umgang mit der pandemie
hat dieser gesellschaften atomisiert
aber schweden vielleicht werde ich schon
nicht geschlossen schweden hat die
schule nicht geschlossen ist dann hat
die schulden nicht geschlossen aber im
großen und ganzen war ganz europa und
einem unglaublich aber deutschland ist
auf platz 1 der härtesten kroner
maßnahmen wir haben es wirklich
geschafft der spitzenreiter zu sein das
kann schnell zumal dieses unglaubliche
die als am längsten durchgezogen die
lobbyisten sein soll sich bitte sind
meist die besten
bei allem aber daran arbeiten wollen wir
haben sagen nein dieser gesellschaft hat
deswegen ein gestörtes verhältnis zu
kindern weil sie selber vollkommen
infantil ist dieser gesellschaft schauen
sie sich mal nur drei tage rtl oder ard
die totale infantilisierung und sie
haben ja nicht nur die kinder der
schwierigen haushalten kommen sie haben
diese ganze verwahrlosten mittelstands
blase die jeden freitag für freie for
future auf die straßen geht ich habe
mich in dem milieu umgesehen und ich war
paar mal versucht einem kind nur feige
zu leben wenn es mir zum beispiel sagte
es geht nicht mehr zur schule weil die
welt geht sowieso unter und das ist am
boden da können sie nicht
mal angst des kindes
ein gerät ja ja man muss dem kind eine
zweite chance geben ja genau das habe
ich auch gemacht ich hab ja auch nicht
zugeschlagen ich sage ich entdeckte
furchtbare abgründe in mir angesichts
dieser rotzlöffel die mehr erklären wie
die welt funktioniert und sie haben eine
wissen sie eine eine vergöttlichung von
kinder werden nicht meine wenn ich
kinder sehe mit dem plakat wir haben
keine plan wir haben kein planet b aber
der konnten die ja wenigstens noch
demonstrieren auf die straßen wenn wir
jetzt versuchen auch gern mit den kinder
schließt aber ich muss auch sagen ein
mittel der mittelstands kindern einfach
angst hat kommen die auswertung haben
sie arbeiten der auswertung trotzdem
muss ich noch mal einen haken was haben
sie gedacht die werden ja später sehen
hier also haben die mitarbeiterinnen da
sagte mir der dreijährige sagt mama bald
darf ich maske tragen oder erster
doktorand war vorbei schule gehen wieder
an ein kind hatte kronen die mutter kam
auf die brillante idee ich könnte ja
mein handy in den islam unterricht
teilnehmen kann das geht in deutschland
dann gegen datenschutz wieder nicht also
mehr sondern eine lustige anekdote
klingt nicht wie essen hier gibt und das
ist halt schwierig und was das an
spätfolgen hat kein baby schwimmen kann
man sich das mal vorstellen wir schon
babys erwarte ich habe 26 jährige die
waren total isoliert über zwei jahre das
wird spätfolgen haben wir wissen noch
gar nicht was das alles bei menschen
psychologisch ausgefeilt das war halt
glück ja ja sagt ich gott sagen auch
dazu denn starkes mindset hat und sich
durchsetzen kann aber davon gibt es
leider nicht so viele menschen wie
andere unterstützung brauchen und die
haben wir echt auch in der zeitschrift
kinder lassen kein starkes mainz setzte
eine starke persönlichkeit ist traurig
ihn auch zu glücklich ist auch eine
starke persönlichkeit wahrscheinlich
überhaupt das ja auch anderen in der
runde warum haben sie zum beispiel als
starker persönlichkeit nichts gegen die
kinder nichts für die kinder während der
schließung getan ich frage mich schaut
manchmal da lobt man das meinst du die
starke persönlichkeit aber als die
kinder nicht mehr die schulen durften
haben wir alle auch nichts gemacht oder
doch wer mit kinder lachen schon
aktionen gefahren und haben dagegen was
getan hat da sind viele menschen
unterwegs gewesen aber sie sehen ja
selber das ist ja das schwierige wir
haben ja kaum noch jemand das ist auch
das was sie sagen infantil dass ich in
deutschland traut was zu sagen du musst
ja schon wenn deine meinung hast du auch
öffentlich geäußert ja schon angst haben
denn deswegen finde ich auch frau
wirklich so klasse mit ihrem buch das
ich einfach sagen ich bin da
ausgestiegen weil ich keinen bock mehr
drauf hatte aber wer traut sich das zu
machen wir müssen aufpassen dass wir
angepasst sind ja nicht auffallen ja und
das macht es so schwierig dann wieviel
hat glück dass als beispiel auch als nur
als kunstfigur wie er selber sagt als
künstler gibt es denn die sie auch traum
was zu sagen da glauben sie nicht dass
wenn noch mal die schule geschlossen
sein für die kinder müssten alle
erwachsen hat die strafe ich total ab
und nochmal durch lasst mich total dabei
sind wir wieder da sind die menschen die
jede woche zwei stunden 39 am tag
fernsehen schauen ja die in der pandemie
extrem zugenommen haben jeder vierte
deutsche ist übergewichtig also und das
ist ja die behäbigkeit die sich in allen
gesellschaftsbereichen darstellt ob in
den schulen ob bei den lehrern ob bei
mittelschicht bei unternehmern also
müssen auch mal unternehmer sehen es
gibt ja nicht nur die guten unternehmens
gibt auch die die keinen guten lohn
zahlen damit sie verstehen mit
deutschland und geht so gut habe ich ja
eine streitschrift geschrieben um
hier stimmten
12 34 nicht übergewichtig als was sie
sehen das stimmt nicht ich bin
übergewichtig benutzten das andere gerne
in letzte frage
zudem selbst stellen und das ist sie
waren lange in der politik wie
wahrscheinlich ist es denn das nochmal
auf die bevölkerung schulschließungen
kommen
also ich kann es mir beim besten willen
nicht vorstellen wie man so irre sein
kann dass man bei der jetzigen
virusvariante bei all dem was man ja
schon weiß über das virus was man also
tun kann die verbreitung zu verhindern
bei all den maßnahmen die wir anwenden
können dass man und bei dem wissen
darüber wie schlimm und wie schädlich
die schulschließung war das noch
irgendjemand überhaupt auf diesen
absurden gedanken kommen kann noch mal
die schuhe zu schieben ist die politik
sich entschuldigen
ja aber nicht nur dafür ja es wird genau
da hatte der damalige
bundesgesundheitsminister recht dass es
da einiges geben wird für das man sich
wenn sie verteilen sollte und aber die
entschuldigung zum beispiel von frau
merkel kam ja nicht jetzt zum beispiel
einem großen interview gegeben ja und
das ist mir ehrlich gesagt am ende auch
egal ich möchte einfach dass es den
kindern besser geht und ich möchte alles
dafür tun dass wir das aufholen können
was da schiefgelaufen ist das wird ein
riesen kraftakt und dass wir vor allen
dingen in der zukunft und darum geht es
vor allen dingen nicht die gleichen
fehler machen um noch weitere schüler
generationen wirklich abzuhängen und in
den abgrund zu schicken eher glücklich
oder mit die kinder jetzt vernünftig
aufwachsen müssen wir erwachsenen dann
vielleicht vorbild sein und selber auch
keine masken mittragen wieder normalität
einkehren lassen
so einfach ist das nicht es geht ist ja
nicht jetzt nur die maske sind ganz
viele faktoren nein wir müssen
in wege vorzeigen und wir müssen ihnen
möglichkeiten bieten und damit sie aus
ihrem aus ihrer welt aus ihren
tretbooten aus ihrem ksl rauskommen das
ist das wichtigste erstmal ja und da
sehe ich im moment halt kein kein
fortschritt da sind wir schon wieder so
weit zurückgefallen und deshalb möchte
ich da mich auch immer wieder stark
machen und bringt das thema an und und
rede auch darüber nicht nur reden
natürlich versuchen auch dinge zu tun
aber
man muss jetzt auch immer wieder
ansprechen weil es ist jetzt so
kinderarmut denkt man immer an afrika ja
da gibt es auch aber wir haben sie auch
hier in deutschland ja ja wir haben sie
auch hier in deutschland die kinder
diese als arm bezeichnen haben eltern
die haben mich fernsehen die haben genug
geld für tabak und alkohol ich gucke
rtl2 regelmäßig ich bin gut informiert
und ich kann noch mal sagen es ist nicht
die frage der materiellen ausstattung
nein nein aber auch aber möchte ich habe
der dass das kind muss so eine
möglichkeit haben dass es wenn wenn wenn
es diese idioten zu hause lebt und da
ist alles gewalt hätten sich irgendwo
denn tagsüber vielleicht irgendwo anders
hin kann aber wo soll es hingehen war ja
und deshalb sind zur einrichtung wichtig
deswegen dass ihr konzepte allmacht des
staates
es geht darum dass jedes kind doch
irgendwie die chance haben muss einen
zugang zu bildung zu bekommen sein leben
auf die reise gegeben ich bin doch darum
geht ja gar nicht darum dass das sich
dass ich verneinen will dass die
elternverantwortung haben oder dass der
staat alles regeln kann aber statt kann
etwas tun und er hat ein vernünftiges
bildungssystem bereitzustellen was dann
auch offen ist hier als politikerin
hatte genug zeit sich zu kümmern habe
ich sagte sie als politikerin hatten
genug zeit das in zukunft sehr gut
verstanden aber sie haben nichts dazu
gesagt ein kleines sie haben recht herr
brunner wäre mir ganz recht gewesen ja
ich glaube im parlament wie keine andere
glaube ich für dieses thema immer wieder
geworben und die als
oppositionsabgeordnete die regierung der
immer wieder vor mir her getragen es hat
mich vielleicht hätte man noch mehr
machen müssen aber ich glaube ich habe
da wir haben ja auch selbst die
reißleine
die ihr buch halt aber ich habe ja
trotzdem dich auf mich würde ja nach wie
man einzusetzen weil das beschäftigt
mich auch nach der politik weiter das
stimmt ein bisschen ein wichtiges thema
und jetzt gehen wir eine kurze werbung
und dann kommt die these von herr bruder
und ich glaube er hat ordentlich
temperatur das wird lustig bis gleich
was hat dich
[Musik]
also da kann ich dann ein lauter krach
und nicht ernst nehmen als sogenannten
experten
herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren bei den 85 plätzen fünf meinungen
vor jeder von uns hat ein thema
mitgebracht was ihn bewegt tage als
freud oder schockiert
[Musik]
so nicht rüber jiechi jörges wetten seit
august aber niemand von den politischen
parteien traut sich zu sagen ja das
wollen wir einfach nur freiheit diese
grün-roten der dar und führen
hochtrabende debatten über die rettung
des weltklimas und um die füße russland
die ratten das thema ist viel zu wichtig
um es nur derart zu überlassen lasst den
leuten soll man den spaß wir sehen da
etwas was eigentlich fatale ist in der
politik bei den journalisten deren job
ist es doch gerade abweichende meinungen
zu fügen und sie sollen dem doch auch
richtig dürfte sein
dass conti zum manko vielleicht einmal
kurz ein
doch das sind übliche anorak träger
ausgesprochen
ich habe meinen beifahrer meine sache
immer bekommt wer kümmert sich darum
niemand tut es ja man muss ja ganz knapp
drüber sprechen das ist ein fakt nicht
fertig richtig durch die ausgabe von
journalismus einfach
die verlautbarung der politik zu
hinterfragen
[Musik]
wir sind zurück in der kurzen pause
haben ein glücklicher und der bruder
sich optisch ein bisschen angepasst und
passives gemacht und jetzt kommen in 15
von herrn bruder ja ich sagte schon das
problem ist nicht dass wir zu wenig
statt haben wir haben zu viel staat wir
haben einen wohlfahrtsstaat der außer
rand und band geraten ist der familien
und alleinstehende und alleinerziehende
mütter das inzwischen auch ein beruf
versorgt wir haben ein klima paket die
leute kriegen zuschüsse zu den
heizungskosten jetzt gibt es sogar habe
ich neulich gehört ein tank rabatt der
sich aber nicht da hinaus wird dass die
preise sinken können so dass
irgendwelche lieferanten zwischendurch
mehr verdienen es ist zu viel staat da
und das beste beispiel für die konfusion
für die verwirrung für diesen absurden
idealismus der staatsbehörden ist das 9
euro ticket das neue neurotiker wissen
dass es der reine zynismus wenn ich
darauf angewiesen wäre würde ich nicht
wirklich massiv empören und mit diesem
ticket versuchen irgendwo nach sambia zu
fahren oder zu fliegen nur um diesem
milieu zu entkommen 9 euro wie kommt man
auf nein warum nicht zehn euro warum
nicht 7 euro 50 wie viele fachleute
haben wochenlang da zusammengesessen und
sich dieses ding ausgedacht und das
ergebnis sehen wir es findet kein
umstieg von der strasse auf die bahn
statt ich habe die bilder über pfingsten
sehr genossen das hat mir sehr gut
gefallen wo die leute im zug stehen und
zwar so im zug stehen kein abstand keine
masken keine hygienemaßnahmen offenbar
kommt es in solchen situationen nicht
darauf an und es wird den leuten den
eindruck vermittelt der staat das was
sie wollen der staat macht was für sie
erscheint ihnen was gibt ihnen die
möglichkeit von berg das garden nach
kiel für neun euro zu fahren dauert zwei
drei tage mit einer regional verfügen
aber immerhin
und das ist dass es sozusagen die
ursünde die überversorgung die
einmischung des staates in alles und bei
diesen neuen euro es ist wirklich ein
gigantischer bluff ist ein großversuch
um zu sehen wie weit man die leute in
die irre führen kann verarschen kann sie
kriegen in die eine tasche das neue in
euro ticket reingesteckt und aus der
anderen tasche kriegen sie ihr geld
wieder entzogen alsfeld in einem am sie
leider vollkommen recht es fehlt jedes
bewusstsein für wirtschaftliche
zusammenhänge dass auch gymnasien heute
wirtschaft kein pflichtfach ist absolut
dass die kinder nicht wissen wie geld
funktioniert oder wie die wertschöpfung
gerade beim neuen euro ticket helfen
nein es würde uns nicht helfen weil das
ist es zu spät für solche maßnahmen aber
so heißt sie würden das finanziert aber
es wird schon mal nicht schlecht wenn
die leute begreifen würden dass sie ein
neurotiker in selber finanzieren unter
anderem auch darüber dass das eine
achtprozentige inflation gibt von der
die leute enteignet werden so aber das
gerät in den hintergrund weil er
ständigen wir hilfen sub zuschüsse
subventionen gibt übrigens gibt es ganze
berufsstände die davon leben leute zu
beraten wie sie und subventionen
herankommen das ist auch ein absolutes
wohlfahrt stadt glücklich denn 109 euro
ticket sich gekannt habe ich nicht nein
nein sie machen sich auch nicht
haltbares offen ist für mich ist das der
davon profitieren ja aber ich stimme vor
in einem zurückbilden
eine zeuge finden waren zu stehen und
und nähe also dass das leid der horror
für mich jetzt und meine beine ich hatte
heute besuch von einer damit die immer
mit der bahn versuchte es ist nicht mehr
auszuhalten das ist nicht es ist so voll
du kannst das nicht aus ist eine
katastrophe also ich kann das nicht
bestätigen eaton gestern erst der klasse
von warschau nach berlin gefahren das
war okay
erzählt aber nicht das neue hotel in dem
ich schon den ersten chance und gehen
sie denn mit bauherr bruder
ja ich mein herr bruder beschreibt die
situation ziemlich zu treffen und wir
als bürger haben natürlich da auch eine
gehörige mitschuld also ich habe dass er
sehr intensiv verfolgt auch in den
letzten jahrzehnten dass die politiker
die neue wohltaten aufrufen dass die
gewählt werden das aber
diejenigen die irgendwie versuchen etwas
zu streichen dann auch mit hinweis ja
vollkommen richtig dass das ja aus dem
steuergeld kommt dass das ja
letztendlich das geld ist der der bürger
was da ausgegeben wird dass das aber
überhaupt nicht verfängt und dass die
jeden politiker so gnadenlos abgestraft
werden dass im prinzip einpacken können
das lernt jeder politiker sehr sehr
schnell und deswegen habe ich darauf
wenig hoffnung dass sich das grundlegend
ändert ich hoffe frau suding die fdp
dazu gehören sie jetzt nicht mehr aber
die fdp hat ihr den tank rabatt jetzt
auch gemacht der nähe stark scheint
überall angekommen zu sein obwohl
sachsen ob beim neuen euro ticket und
eigentlich ist es ja der steuerzahler
der das alles ermöglicht ihr natürlich
das ist ja genau das was wo wir ein
bewusstsein entwickeln müssten dass das
was man den menschen aus der tasche stil
zieht aus der einen tasche
verwurstet wird in einen staatsapparat
und dann zugeteilt wie ist wiederum
macht die fdp dass sie macht es nicht
alleine sie machen alle politiker machen
der mieter kann und meine partei sich
auch nicht ausnehmen das ist sicherlich
auch ganz große versuchung da
ja das wohlwollen sich des bürgers zu
erkaufen
weil das ist auch einer der gründe warum
sie die politische bühne verlassen haben
nein das hatte bei mir ganz persönliche
gründe ich wollte einfach mein leben
zurück das hat weniger was mit
programmatik zu tun wo ich unzufrieden
war das da hättest ja noch genug gegeben
wo ich aber wir wollen alle unser leben
zurück weil sie alle wurden alle und ja
ich hab es jetzt zurück jedenfalls total
verzogen wie können wir es ihnen
zurückgeben das war eine
spitz ausgedrückt die menschen haben ihr
leben alle noch nicht so zurück nach dem
locker und sie haben es lange noch nicht
so mit und das meine ich damit wir
wollen unser leben zurück ich habe mein
leben zurück aber die meisten haben
erleben nicht zurück die meistens in
völlig lost die wissen überhaupt gar
nicht nur vorn wo hingesetzt und wo
haben sie schon apathisch angst lässt
jetzt große geschenke vom staat tank
rabatt euro also große geschenke sind
mir immer suspekt da war ja auch man
kriegt nichts geschenkt man kriegt
nichts geschenkt es kommt immer eine
rechnung die schon bisschen professor
sie der begründer der positiven
psychologie und das ist das was wir
gemacht haben mit der gesellschaften wir
haben die verantwortung abkommen wenn
ich heute sehe der titel vom stern ja
können wir uns die reichen noch leisten
auf lindner abgebildet ich weiß gar
nicht was da war ich weiß ja politiker
werde immer gerne dafür genommen und ich
habe
auch nicht wirklich sagen wir zogen an
ist das haben wir darauf gemacht ja aber
dass das ist genau das ist genau der
punkt also wir müssen den menschen immer
mehr verantwortung geben und auch sagen
dass sie eben selbst für ihre ausbildung
verantworlichen selbst weiterbildungs
man fertig sind und das ist genau das
was wir heute an möglichkeiten haben
auch durch die digitalisierung aber das
hat er richtig schön gesagt der staat
richtet ja irgendwie ich kenne menschen
die kommen einfach durch und dann haben
wir noch eins geschaffen werden solle
zwei gesellschaft geschaffen das war wie
in der pandemie die dämpfen die die
nicht impfen und so haben wir geschaffen
die die reichen die die arbeitsplätze
schaffen sind die bösen ausbeuter da
gibt es sicherlich schwarze schafe wie
überall aber es gibt auch viele die
arbeitsplätze schaffen die halt eben
einen großen beitrag leisten wenn man
mal sieht jetzt wird gefordert neueste
idee 57 prozent spitzensteuersatz
naja wenn ich mir angucke nicht eben
beschrieben habe das sind 0 1 prozent
plus eben ein prozent also sagen wir das
wirklich so wer soll das dann irgendwann
noch finanzieren und das muss auch mal
klar sein wo sehen sie heute noch ein
unternehmer der auch mal in die politik
geht der sagt ich setz mich mit denen
auseinander weil die so weltfremd sind
und vom normalen arbeiter leben genau
sie vom unternehmerleben weg sind da
kommen menschen oder zum
bewerbungsgespräch mit 24 noch eine
kleine anekdote fahren wollen sich in
die politik gehen weil ich möchte auch
nicht mit zu vielen lehrern darunter
sind 121 lehrer dabei bei 7 65
abgeordneten die zweithöchste zahl nach
china brauchen wir das ich bin eher
dafür dass von einer expertenrunde
kriegen wenn wir das kriegen können dann
bin ich dabei ich habe frau merkel
angeschrieben sie hatte man ja mal
nichts tun ist ja auch das stimmt nicht
und ich habe frau merkel angeschrieben
und sie hatte eine ausschreibung suchte
zwei leute zwei psychologen mit
doktortitel die helfen der regierung ein
neues gesicht zu gehen ich hab sie
angeschrieben dass ich weder studiert
habe noch einen doktortitel aber ich
wusste wie es geht und ich gebe auch für
die erste beratung ohne berechnung was
bekam ich zurück ein standardschreiben
schön dass sie frau merkel unter partei
weiter wo es ein bisschen
selbstüberschätzung direkt frau merkel
raten zu wollen ich hatte gute idee
gehabt und hätte ich auch heute noch
aber das problem ist auch wenn sie wenn
sie heute leute suchen wenn ich junge
menschen suchen
kreative leute um mich zu unterstützen
und ihnen die sind alle nicht mehr
belastbar das sind alle nicht mehr
belastbar sind also haben schon burnout
wenn sie ankommen mit mein tempo von
neun jahren mit manchem bekommen die gar
nicht mit also da sind die gleich nach
drei tagen sind die dann hören die auch
schon wieder auf und und und ja ihr habt
mir warum ist es so
schwer flüssig genug leid die perfekte
überleitung zur these von herrn limbeck
geschafft
und deswegen machen wir haben direkt
weiter ja genau das dass genau das der
punkte die sind heute so was von in
watte gepackt von ihren eltern die haben
nicht mehr gelernt irgendwie erst
schaufeln dann schütteln sich die hände
schmutzig zu machen das fängt ja schon
damit an man müll rauszubringen oder zu
hause zu helfen das heißt es ist alles
da sollen alle studieren steht ihre
total dass wir das studium auf dieselbe
ebene stellen wie handwerk wenn ich mit
konzernen sprechen mit führungskräften
sagen ja leer ohne master studium nehmen
wir gar keinen zum zum praktikum das
heißt wir haben immer mehr versucht hier
eine wissens elite zu schaffen ja die
aber dafür selber nichts machen musste
um einen guten job einstieg zu haben und
wenn sich die neuesten studien anschauen
nachgewiesen wenn der handwerker bis die
feier wird es für meister titel hast du
am anfang mehr geld später hat dann der
studierte so sieben bis acht jahre
später mehr geld aber am ende haben
beide ungefähr ihre 1,3 millionen
erwirtschaftet laut statistik und ich
glaube wir müssen halt einfach eine
andere haltung wieder haben und dass wir
anpacken können und da muss ich leider
einmal der politik in die indy in die
integrierte sprechen habe gesehen im
urteil da gab es auf einmal wieder
nachbarschaftshilfe das heißt wenn eine
katastrophe da ist können wir das
irgendwann und wir stehen vor der
katastrophe dieses land gegen die wand
zu fahren wir sind nirgendwo mehr gut
ich rede gerade mit einem
weltmarktführer mit ingenieuren die
sagen china hat längst das know-how
übernommen wir kriegen es noch niemals
bei formate klaren beiden champions aber
die sind alle leise wo sehen sie mal
mittelstand unternehmer ja der wirklich
erfolgreich in deutschland arbeitsplätze
schafft der aufsteht und was sagt der
letztes für mich rupp von id die meisten
mittelstands unternehmer sind die die
chefin aber dafür nicht im mittelpunkt
stehen wollen und auch nicht müssen
sondern die einfach für dieses land
leiste ich eine frage an wann immer sie
ausgegrenzt sind weil 7 1 waren leistung
ja in deutschland nicht mehr doch neid
in den wirtschaftsjournalisten
eigentlich ausgewählte ich habe viele
unternehmen wird und viele wollen das
auch gar nicht viele wollen nicht ins
rampenlicht die sind aber in ihren
eigenen dörfern in eigenen community
sind die sehr stark die unterstützen
fußballvereine fort aber die brauchen
nicht die große bühne und sind trotzdem
großartig unternehmer aber ich hätte mir
heute morgen eine frage gestellt ich
habe gewusst wo wir sie heute abend rede
mich ja okay die jugend ist voll
geworden ab welchem jahrgang sehen sie
das denn also wer ist für sie jung an
welchem jahrgang sagen sie denen es
work-life-balance wichtiger als jetzt
das scheffel nadal muss man die
turnerischen website anschauen dort
nicht komplett dabei also auch der
jahrgang 1992 ja ich bin ja genauso
sinnlos waren schlecht nein ich bin ich
würde nicht sagen dass ich eine ausnahme
wenn ich habe manchmal das gefühl wenn
man direkten jugend so verteufelt es
gibt ja auch wirklich fleißiger in den
herrscher jetzt machen wir das
schwarz-weiße schaut deswegen auch das
dass wir auch so krass geschrieben weil
über die grauen reden wir nicht den
graubereich gibt es ja immer aber ist ja
genau das war es ein glücklicher sagt
die fragen erst mal wie sind meine
arbeitszeiten kriechen den handy
griechen mac ja wir haben hofer ware
schreibtische wir sind dann meine
arbeitszeiten das sind fragen die er
stellt allem bin ich in meinem stopp in
meiner altersgruppe es genau dasselbe da
sind auch vorbilder als könne man
darüber haushalt blöd da gesagt hat mir
fehlt auch bei meinem alter den 55
irgendein 50 dadurch ganz häufig bei
meinen beratungen trainings ja wissen
sie ich habe ja nicht mehr lange da soll
ich haben sie kinder wie fitness so für
ihre kinder wenn sie sagen dass kriege
ich jetzt auch noch hin warum weil ich
bin 25 jahre dabei wenn ich mal raus für
die gibt's eine große abteilung das habe
ich auch noch und da ist auch keine
leistungsbereitschaft mehr darf ich
ihnen erklären warum ganz kurz ich habe
die zahlen nicht im kopf habe die haben
sie bestimmt ein großer anteil der
erwerbstätigen hängt an den öffentlichen
diensten handwerker leute die wie sie
und ich glöckler einen eigenen beruf
haben und eine eigene firma haben sind
inzwischen die minderheit über 50
prozent der leute die ein einkommen
haben mitziehen es vom staat vom land
und von der gemeinde und von diesen
leuten wird keine besondere leistung
verlangt haben 1,2 millionen beamte ja
ich habe es vorhin gesagt haben menschen
nach der gallup studie 17 die leisten
wollen 68 prozent die in der mitte sind
hier alles nach vorschrift noch mit
einer drei millionen selbständige und
mittelschnellen millionen die werte nur
noch schaffen aber es hält schon eine
ganze weile vor das ist nichts neues
außerdem wollte ich noch mal sagen
welche der älteste bin es bringt nicht
viel über die schreckliche jugend zu
schimpfen das hat noch jede distanziert
er war auch schon getan haben
eigentlich nur ein wort sagen wissen sie
das ist eine sie haben leider vollkommen
recht verfahren das gegen gegen die wand
ist es eine totale bankrotterklärung und
dann gibt es seltsame
kontraproduktive ansätze zb die
verehrung für greta in diesem land nicht
dass seine junge verhaltensgestörte frau
zum idol einer ganzen gesellschaft
werden kann zeigt nur wie
verhaltensgestört die ganze gesellschaft
ist ich war immer der meinung man muss
erst mal mehr leistung bringen zeigen
dass man mehr kann und dann kann man
mehr erfordern aber sie hat immer so die
sagen ich muss erst mal geld kriegen
dann mache ich auch mehr dann versuchen
immer zu erklären so funktioniert das
nicht wenn ich morgen keinen job mehr
hat er überhaupt keinen job und und
nicht wüsste was ich anfangen sollte
dann würde ich irgendwo hingehen zu
einer firma wird sagen pass mal auf ich
putzte jetzt eine woche dort zehn tage
deine bude mache ich alles putzig
kostenlos will ich nicht dafür haben
wenn du zufrieden bestellt sich nach
zehn tagen da würde mich einstellen nach
zehn tagen will er wird zufrieden ja und
nach vier fünf wochen hätte ich dann den
ersten angestellten zweiten und dann der
firma aufgemacht ja aber nein man will
erstmal will erst mehr bekommen und ich
mach doch nicht bevor ich nicht mehr
bekomme ich machte erst was ich nicht
was bekomme ich sage immer du musst erst
mal beweisen dass du das wert ist sagte
bekommen möchtest dann sehen die aber
nicht so und haben sie können alten
lagen so dass manchmal damit bestellten
anlagen so ich spreche mit einem
vorstand der sag das mal auf ich habe
hier ein budget von 50 millionen für
eines unserer größten talente im
förderungs pool da kann der internet
kampf in dem baum muss dafür von münchen
nach berlin ziehen
31 jahre alt da sagt er mein kind ist
gerade in die schule kommen wir fühlen
uns jetzt in münchen wohl ich gehe nicht
mehr weg das heißt wir wollen auch noch
finde ich total schlimm finde es schlimm
wenn ihr anteil haben kind bleiben wenn
sich wohl für einen stopp stopp stopp
stopp ich finde es schlimm wenn jemand
heute nicht mehr flexibel sagt bei
seiner chance die ich habe eine eigene
company aufzubauen der soll mit seiner
familie nach nach berlin ziehen aber
nein jetzt hab ich mich ein gericht
heute flexibilität man andere stadt
kennenlernen ein anderes bundesland
gelernt weiter auch den horizont
ich habe es ein bisschen gelesen sie war
auch in den usa ja das habe ich auch
gemacht hat mir sehr den horizont
geöffnet ich bin sowieso dafür dass
kinder zwangsrekrutiert werden sollen in
einem alter von 16 17 und auslandsjahr
machen sollte man bei einer anderen
familie leben sonst hätte ich mega ich
bin dafür dass im studium mindestens ein
praktikumsjahr dabei ist mal ein jahr
schneidern und einer klippe über die
schulter schauen oder dann in der pr
frau so denn sind sie auch dafür also
zwang sehr
praktikumsjahr ausland und dass man auch
bereits ein muss für jeden job auf
flexiblen die stadt in die städte zu
ziehen sagt nicht für jeden aber ich
sage das so eine gewisse flexibilität
brauchen ja das ist mir als als
freiheitsliebende person einfach einfach
too much also ja es stimmt das und wir
haben da eine entwicklung ich habe die
kann man auch gar nicht übersehen aber
ich glaube schon dass es auch gut ist
wenn menschen gucken was für sie richtig
ist wenn sie auch mal zu einem aber wir
wissen ja nicht sein aber gerichte ja
aber da wäre es doch gut wenn wir
versuchen wir als gesellschaft doch eher
zu investieren menschen zu ermutigen
genau das rauszufinden was will denn
eigentlich war ich glaube dass ein
mensch dann am produktivsten ist am
besten ist am kreativsten schönsten und
tollsten lösungen findet und auch am
meisten bereit ist über alle maßen viel
zu arbeiten wenn er oder sie das
richtige tut also es ist ja manchmal
sonst so sind wir wahrscheinlich alle
irgendwie stückweit aufgewachsen
derjenige der am meisten arbeit am
meisten tut der ist wie der beste mensch
aber aber das ist mal was gegen die
sagen ganz klar zu mehr glück ganz ganz
viele junge leute sagen ich möchte auch
ganz so berühmt werden wie sie oder wie
du aber so viel arbeiten möchte ich bin
ich sagen dass solche auch immer wieder
vom anbieter weiter ich wäre auch gern
so erfolgreich weil alle so leben aber
ich will nicht so genau ja und das ist
das gibt sicherlich mehr extrem ist das
auch nicht gut aber nur zu sagen dass
viel arbeiten per se ein wert ist finde
ich unterstütze wenn man nämlich in oslo
ist wenn man das richtige findet dann
kann man aber wir wirklich das richtige
das ist doch das thema heute schon die
gehen machen ja
ja das kann ja auch helfen natürlich im
jahr was nach zwölf jahren die eng
gepresst und wenn man 17 ist ein abitur
immer wenn jemand reden aber einmal ins
ausland würde
gegen leben
ausland haben sie ein praktikum im
ruhrgebiet geboren letzte von drei an
die commerzbank muss familien sehr
einfachen verhältnis haben eine gute
kindheit gehabt hat jetzt leider oder
gott sei dank nicht irgendwelche
geschichten da laufen sehr behütet aber
mir war irgendwie gleich mal auf dem
campingplatz groß geworden ist mir zu
klein ist mir zu eng und ich hatte oft
glück ich hatte eine referendarin an der
schule ist war die iris weber die damals
sagte geben ein jahr nach amerika gesagt
getan bin ja nach amerika das hat mir
einfach noch mal die welt haben das
gezeigt und da heißt jedes kind
gearbeitet ich hatte jeden tag zwei
stunden sport und geest kind
tellerwäscher tatsächlich haben rasend
gemacht dasselbe ich sage ich morgen am
tag die wieder rasen mähen wenn alles
weg ist ich habe geschaut meine ersten
1000 dollar von ihnen für mich war klar
ich möchte kein millionär ja ich möchte
einen porsche fahren ob das jetzt
erstrebenswerte nicht ist oder nicht für
mich war das so und dann will ich wieder
gekommen meine mutter sagte bis zur
lehrer dein bruder studiert es gibt nur
taxi fahren ich hatte drei nebenjobs und
habe während meiner lehre schon mehr
geld verdient als mit dem lehrgeld
eine alles was sie erzählen ist google
das passt ja in diese zahl stimmt und
sie müssen sich mal auch anschauen waren
auch es heute ankommt was die
öffentlichen debatten sind die
frauenquote das gender sternchen und vor
allem was ich für auch korrupte weiter
das bedingungslose grundeinkommen das
unterschlägt als eine maßnahme zum
frieden sein sollte er wurde als am ende
der sendung ein ein statement werden
können sie eine positive sache dem
wunsch der jungen einer guten uhr greift
weil eins abgewinnen ja natürlich diese
jugend will zum beispiel nicht kämpfen
was ich ganz toll findet nicht die idee
dass man seine werte verteidigen soll
ist in dieser gesellschaft nicht mehr
vorhanden das finde ich ganz positiv das
verhindert ein zweiter stalingrad
ja ja ja das sehe ich positiv aber
schauen sie es ist völlig egal wie ich
es sehe wir können doch nicht darauf
vorbeischauen das wirklich merck sein
generationen stadt geweckt stadt
generationenwechsel stattgefunden hat
einen campari zu viel
es ist nicht mehr so dass arbeit was 10
max hat glaube ich diesen genialen satz
gesagt reichtum ist gar ohne arbeit so
ähnlich und darauf kommt es nicht machen
wir haben über 100 länder lehrstühle in
der bundesrepublik ich glaube für hoch
und tiefbau gibt es einen präsentierten
weniger lehrstühle dieser gesellschaft
ist ein schweizweit marsch ist am ende
angekommen ich möchte mich noch das buch
ganz kurz von frau suding empfehlen es
ist sehr gut zu sollten aber reinlesen
auch mehr bin ich zu dem krieg erfahren
was ist damit ja einen schönen abend zu
bis bald
[Musik]
ja aber das kann man schwer
nachvollziehen ja aber darum sind sie
groß geworden